CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleeman is
with us along with chief legal
correspondent Jan Crawford Ricky I want
to start with you
she has already said she is terrified he
has said this is crazytown and a smear
he's also asking for fair process
what does fair process look for both
sides this morning well there certainly
is no fair process here what you're
dealing with is there should have been
an FBI investigation in order to have
fair process why do I say there's no
fair process today you've got one person
who is a trained advocate who has 55
minutes and then you have the Democrat
excited when they get to Brett Kavanaugh
they get five minutes each you cannot
develop a line of questioning in five
minutes well but I mean if I could break
in here I mean they could the
Republicans have chosen to give their
questions to one person that's part of
their strategy Democrats could have done
that as well if they wanted to bring in
a seasoned attorney who was is why not
they all the best questions for the
Democratic senators why not give it all
if we're looking at advise and consent
of the Senate is he fit and if that is
the real question here then at that
point in time it's their responsibility
it's not to hire a prosecutor who by the
way by nature does not have the same
skillset as a criminal defense lawyer
criminal defense moments for her to this
isn't what she her no what she normally
does is she helps a victim tell the
truth in the idea that they're going to
prosecute the accused here of course
we're backwards
it's inside-out she cannot possibly have
practice at preparing victims in a way
to be cross-examined the way a criminal
defense lawyer and also to your point I
think what's impossible to overstate is
how different the United States Senate
is with full gavel-to-gavel coverage on
every television network America
watching than a courtroom in Arizona
where you're talking to a jury I mean
it's a completely different stage Jan
for the for the Senators here advising
consent is what they have to do over the
look of the
tire nomination but this is really today
what this could arguably be just about
that one alleged night I mean which is
separate and apart I mean it's a part of
the larger advising consent but it is a
separate thing that they seem to be
trying to get to the bottom of today and
I thought some of the polling that Gail
was mentioning earlier was interesting
because the American people a lot of
merit they've not made up their minds
yet I mean the American people are kind
of with dirt was drawing their judgment
until they see how this testimony
unfolds as opposed to it was very clear
when it would during the Anita Hill
era it was very clearly against her and
those numbers changed I mean that became
more against her after she testified in
fact or it's very at the contrast to
Yale Law School this time where Yale Law
School has already made up its mind that
they believe Ford and not Cavanaugh so I
think that the hearing is a moment
obviously and it's that you can't
understate the significance that they
are going to present their side of the
story they're going to be questioned by
different types of questioners and then
the American people will decide and
that's going to be significant because
who advises in consents the Senate and
at some point that becomes a political
question he said she said case well it
is in the way it's being presented but
we have to remember we are not in a
criminal court where the burden of proof
is on the government and in this case
her to prove her story beyond a
reasonable doubt so we are in a place
dealing with advise and consent but
ultimately is it that we believe his
denial or are we looking for reasons to
believe her or to discredit her what
does the prosecutor do in her role now
dealing with her do they discredit her
or do they eviscerate her well and Jen
we're not dealing with a court of law
here so we're in this kind of mushy
fuzzy area in which we have a little bit
but also not but in a court of law
you're only sometimes not allowed to
bring in a lot of other evidence outside
of the specific question you're
interrogating so the question of
Cavanaugh's behavior in high school is
that relevant or is it bringing in a lot
of thing that sounds bad but but isn't
associated with the question about what
happened this is not a court of law
I mean this would never have been
prosecuted this case thirty years later
with no contemporaneous evidence it
would be very different this would never
be in a court of law at this point now
so yeah I mean it's in many ways
anything goes whatever these senators
want to put out there Cavanaugh is going
to have to answer questions across the
spectrum of his his life about his
behavior murder crime today oh I think
he does oh I think she does do know I do
but she's going to be seen though and
what was striking even within the Thomas
hearings people who supported Thomas
were shocked at how Hill looked credible
she is going to seem credible and
already we see no one I mean you look at
Yale Law School everyone is saying that
they believe her already so he's got to
change that well the real question is
how she affects those swing votes all
right yeah we'll see thanks to both of
you